[Music]
where did you go squirrel
on the ground
[Music]
let me tell you something
I formed the Guardians
[Music]
[Applause]
that girl died but then she came back
came back and totaled dick oh please he
left out some important information but
that is the gist of it
[Music]
my sacred mission
is to create the perfect Society
it's perfect
[Music]
I want you all to know that I'm grateful
to find beside my friends
incinerate them
thank you
we're always searching for a family
until we found each other
are you ready for One Last Ride
we'll all fly away together
into the forever
a beautiful sky
[Applause]
whoever it was that you were in love
with it sounds more like her hers do not
bring me into them
knock it off what
never noticed how black your eyes were
they were replaced by my father as a
method of torture he he picked a pretty
set
foreign
[Music]